what how stupid would I be to do that I
didn't say yes stupid guys I didn't is
this camera on me yes that's favorite
our Kelly breaks his silence after being
charged with 10 counts of aggravated
criminal sexual abuse which occurred
after lifetimes explosive six-part
documentary series surviving or Kelly
aired can you describe the physical
abuse
god I can't take another day I can't do
this anymore
t spoke with our Kelley's former protege
Stephanie Edwards also known as sparkle
in January when I came along nobody back
me up like I stated in in in the piece
you know there was me before there was
me too
you know I I was at it alone I went out
of the loan and you know I'm happy to
see the me to movement times up movement
are back in these people I wish they
were back when I was you know coming up
and and had the story to tell but you
know nobody believed but now people are
saying be R&B singer gave his first
interview since being newly charged to
CBS this morning's Gayle King and in a
teaser released Tuesday Kelly continues
to deny all claims against him only
going back to the bass and they trying
to add all of this stuff now to that to
make all of the stuff that's going on
now feels real to people but the past is
relevant with you with underage girls
absolutely no it's not why because for
one I beat my case King pressed Kelly
asking him to comment on the recent
charges women have come forward and said
our Kelly had sex with me when I was
under the age of 18 or Kelly was abusive
to me emotionally and physically and
verbally this reason these aren't old
rumor not true whether they're almost
new almost why would you not true then
the Kelly got emotional how stupid would
it be for me to with my crazy pass and
what I've been through
oh right now I just think I need to be a
monster and hold girls against they will
chain them up in my basement
and and don't let them eat and don't let
them out I didn't do this stuff this is
not for an exclusive preview of part two
of King's interview and to hear from
King herself
tune into et on TV Wednesday March 6